ich würde ihnen gerne mal allen ein foto
zeigen was aufgenommen wurde in
großburgwedel bei hannover
dort sehen wir das und wir kennen auch
das aus dem frühjahr bereits kein
klopapier mehr vorhanden ist teilweise
so erzählte uns der juni das foto
aufgenommen hat er dann in einem anderen
bereich auch nur eine packung kaufen
durfte weil das sozusagen schon bereits
rationiert wurde also hat die kanzlerin
mit ihrer rede für panik gesorgt da
schon nein hat sie nicht weil man muss
ja sagen selbst für einen lock down
haben wir es geschafft deutschland zu
versorgen versorgt zu sein in allen
handelns untereinander in klopapier
hab's nicht genug ausreichend na ja also
ich habe glaube ich 150
telefonkonferenzen und videokonferenzen
nur zu den wundern sich
und es war natürlich spitzen da wenn
plötzlich wirkliche hamsterkäufe gemacht
wird aber es war nie ein notstand an
dieser stelle da und auf jeden fall über
alle versorgungs artikel war immer eine
grundversorgung sichergestellt im
übrigen auch im sinn vergessen können
sie können sie garantieren den deutschen
dass genügend klopapier da sein wird
aber aus klopapier alleine kommen sie
nicht an